remember me well I remember many things
I went to the [ __ ] dagger which was
amazing and they gave me like a tour
what's your favorite food my favorite
food I love pizza
Justin says oh the next time I see you
at the junket I'll bring you a Pixar
taco you said cheese pizza so far this
is best interview I've ever had in my
entire life
do you have a hidden talent I think I'm
a pretty good cook well you don't have
any hidden talents they're all on
display I can't in the movie on the red
hoodie ultimately we chose the red
hoodie because we knew that when we go
into the land of the dead that he was
gonna be in this very very colorful
environment we always wanted to be able
to spot him in the frame even if he was
tiny because he's slowly changing into a
skeleton during the course of the film
and we wanted to kind of remind people
of that even though he had his hoodie on
so he did these white stripes that kind
of evoked bones in his arms do you ever
have nerves what's your trick for
getting over it because he had a certain
trick in the film depends because with
every project is different you know the
the kind of like the the thing that I do
but I don't get over it
in a way they help me get out there in a
sense you guys ever get nervous before
performing and what do you do to get rid
of the d'oeuvres oh whoa nerves are
natural for me but but what I just do is
just breathe and just and this is right
when I get into the stage is the
disturbs just leave right when I seem
the first no it's just so much fun you
it's not we are remember me
you